[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans parlement
hebdo 26 minutes pour revenir sur
l'essentiel de la semaine politique et
parlementaire et cette semaine avec tam
tran huy notre invité marie pierre de la
gontrie bonjour je vous êtes sénatrice
et ces femmes qui brosse votre portrait
en quelques traits de plume en jean
marie pierre de la gontrie vous êtes
donc sénatrice socialiste de paris vice
présidente de la commission des lois
vous êtes également avocate de
profession et cette année vous avez fait
campagne aux côtés d'anne hidalgo vous
avez été la responsable de son
association de financement pour la
présidentielle échéance que la candidate
socialiste a terminé avec un score de
moins de 2% dans ce contexte est-ce que
vous jugez aujourd'hui que la nuit pas
permis de sauver le parti socialiste de
la disparition non je ne dirais pas
sauvé de la disparition mais
incontestablement la nuque a permis de
faire apparaître
l'existence de la gauche de répondre à
un besoin que nous on a entendu beaucoup
pendant les campagnes successives de
rassemblement les électeurs nous le
demandait donc après on peux et je le
ferai sans aucune difficulté
à voir des critiques ou des regrets ou
des reproches sur la façon dont tout
cela s'est constitué mais voilà c'est
c'est incontestablement les électeurs
étaient contents de ce rassemblement
étaient contents aussi que le parti
socialiste ce identifie clairement dans
le camp de la gauche parce que sur
certains aspects
voilà mais ce que fait nié que le parti
socialiste risque d'être cantonné à un
rôle supplétifs par rapport à la france
un soumises dans cette union non parce
que d'abord vous l'avez remarqué
lorsqu'on regarde le nombre de députés
finalement la france a soumises à deux
fois plus de députés que
les socialistes alors que ils ont fait
un score 10 fois plus important la
présidentielle donc il ya une vraie
réponse si libre âge vous dire oui et
puis parce que il ya quelque chose mais
ça c'est le problème des socialistes
c'est le nôtre sur lequel il va falloir
qu'on travaille c'est que on a un
ancrage territorial qui est extrêmement
puissant ça tout le monde le sait ce qui
n'est pas le cas la france insoumise
donc notre responsabilité dans les mois
et les années qui viennent ces deux
d'arriver à articuler tout cela mais non
je pense que notre responsabilité demain
ce sera particulier mais c'est à la fois
d'être identifiable et identifié sur un
discours politique et une position ce
positionnement politique clair tout en
faisant partie d'une alliance vous savez
on a connu ça avec la gauche plurielle
enfin j'veux dire des rassemblements de
gauche c'est pas non plus quelque chose
de quasi inédit tout le monde n'a pas
fait partie du rassemblement il ya
certains candidats socialistes qui sont
restés en dissidence notamment à paris
je pense à daniel haran n'étaient pas
des cédantes alors elle été
officiellement investie soutenu par les
neiges aux chalumeaux non non par le
parti social elle est associée oui mais
elle l'a elle a perdu n'avaient pas le
statut du citoyen avec l'âge il y en a
quand même eu d'autres et que que
faut-il faire de ceux qui ont été
vraiment qu'ils se sont inscrits en
dissidence est-ce qu'il faut les exclure
du parti socialiste écoutez nous on a
une règle au parti socialiste c'est que
quand on est en dissidence qui n'est pas
le cas de la mire la rage du tout parce
qu'elle était sûre tenté au manager
compte des réalités sociales absolument
c'était un cas unique taille absolument
on considère qu' on se met ça tu dises
en dehors c'est à dire qu'on n'a pas
besoin de vous exclure vous êtes de vous
même en dehors beaucoup d'ailleurs
eux-mêmes avait dit je me mets en dehors
moi je ne suis pas pour les purges
forcené pour tout dire donc il ya
effectivement lorsque il ya des cas
différents certains ont pu faire perdre
la gauche donc là c'est plus
problématique mais je ne suis pas pour
des purges général je ne vois pas très
bien l'intérêt
les donc sûrs comme carole delga pour
nous un candidat c'est un nom qui sont
des des soutiens qui ont soutenu un des
dissidences je crois que c'est non mais
c'est tout à fait hors de propos
d'imaginer ou d'exclusion d'ailleurs je
ne vois pas sur quel fondement en termes
statutaire bon mais c'est autre chose
effectivement certaines grandes voix de
des socialistes ils se sont engagés
certains pas tous le nail jospin était
très engageant et très engagé et sur la
question la nuque y compris en soutien
la mairie l'âge où ils étaient
pratiquement toutes les semaines sur le
terrain avec elle donc voilà donc je
pense que les candidats dissidents
la question se pose
les soupes des soutiens évidemment non
vous savez le parti socialiste a
toujours de cette particularité que
certains ne reconnaîtront on a toujours
su avoir des avis différents se
confronter est arrivé quand même ensuite
à 100 vous aimez la confrontation oui
mancelle à résoudre c'est à dire
qu'ensuite on s'est trouvé des moyens
donc on n'est pas voilà c'est parti
stalinien des années antérieures il ya
eu quelques confrontations d'ailleurs
dont on va parler cette semaine à
l'assemblée avec la bataille des postes
clefs à l'assemblée et yaël brawn privé
première présidente de l'assemblée
nationale
l insoumis eric coquerel à la tête de la
commission des finances et deux
vice-présidents rassemblement national
l'équation a été délicate et les
critiques ont fusé
on connaît enfin l'ordre du jour du
parlement l'événement ce sera la
déclaration de politique générale
mercredi prochain à l'assemblée
nationale puis au sénat au menu aussi le
projet de loi très attendue sur le
pouvoir d'achat à partir du 18 juillet
en séance et enfin les socialistes et
les communistes à l'initiative au sénat
pour inscrire livi g dans la
constitution défendre le droit à
l'avortement fait consensus mais
l'avenir de ces textes restent très
incertains
c'est donc une femme qui est présidente
de l'assemblée nationale
elle succède à richard ferrand yaël
bronn qui vais l'emporter après deux
tours de scrutin et le retrait du
candidat du rassemblement national les
autres postes clés ont été attribués
cette semaine eric coquerel a notamment
été élu à la présidence de la commission
des finances le récit de cette semaine
intense avec elsa monde un gamma
une femme au perchoir c'est une première
dans l'histoire yale brune piv est
candidate de la majorité élue à la
présidence de l'assemblée nationale
j'accède à cette fonction dans un moment
particulier de notre vie politique la
configuration de notre assemblée est
inédite les français nous enjoignent de
travailler ensemble de débattre plutôt
que de nous battre il ne lui aura fallu
que deux tours de scrutin le
rassemblement national ayant retiré son
candidat sébastien chenu
mercredi élection du bureau de
l'assemblée sont élus vice-présidents de
députés de la majorité présidentielle
deux députés de la coalition de gauche
et deux députés du rassemblement
national élu dès le premier tour grâce à
des voix de la droite et de la majorité
présidentielle une attitude dénoncée par
la nuque c'est un jour très grave
aujourd'hui la macro ni a décidé
d'appuyer les candidats du rassemblement
national de l'extrême droite qui
accèdent à deux vice présidences et un
franchissement de seuil qui est très
inquiétant élection sous haute tension à
la commission des finances
arithmétiquement c'est eric coquerel le
candidat de la nuque qui doit l'emporter
mais de nombreuses suspensions de séance
laisse planer le doute sur une tentative
d'alliance des autres oppositions
finalement c'est l'un souvenus qu'ils
l'emportent pas plus dans la commission
que dans l'ensemble il ya une majorité
absolue pour quiconque et que donc c'est
ça va être aussi intéressant de voir ce
qui se passe dans cette commission en
tant que j'allais dire sur le fait que
l'assemblée nationale au de vienne
plus le centre de gravité politique de
ce prix le candidat du rassemblement
national dénonce l'attitude de la
majorité qui comme il est d'usagé n'a
pas pris part au vote aussi la
responsabilité de la majorité qui s'est
lavé les mains du début à la fin de
cette désignation laissant du ps triché
puisque nubes a présenté comme un
candidat unique alors qu'ils sont quatre
groupes le bureau et les commissions
sont constitués l'assemblée nationale
attend à présent la déclaration de la
première ministre prévue mercredi
est ce que vous vous réjouissez
qu'enfant une femme accède au perchoir
jusqu'à présent détenue par dz oui bien
sûr mais moi ce que je trouve absolument
effarant c'est qu'on trouve ça
exceptionnel c'est la réalité mais
c'est juste normal donc oui je trouve ça
très bien ce qui est assez intéressant
aussi ça a été peut relever c'est que
vous savez il ya des vice présidences
qui supplée donc la présidence pour un
certain nombre de sciences vous le savez
vous le savez bien ils sont il ya six
vice-présidents qui donc se relaient à
tour de rôle cinq femmes s'étaient tous
les partis toutes les groupes pardon on
présentait des femmes à l'exception
d'ailleurs du rassemblement national
donc ça va oui c'est à dire que est-ce
que l'assemblée devient féministe je ne
sais pas mais en tout cas c'est très
bien et après moi je trouve aussi que
lorsqu'on regarde la composition de
toutes ses responsabilités qui sont
moins anodine pour certains ça apparaît
tripatouillage combine était assez plus
important par des institutions c'est au
fond le choc entre le nouveau monde et
l'ancien monde c'est à dire que regarder
on l'a peu on l'a peu évoqué chez les
questeurs questeur c'est ceux qui gèrent
le budget de l'assemblée d'un pass ont
retranscrit live earth et eric ciotti je
ne fais aucun commentaire sur les
personnages même si concernant eric
woerth il y aurait beaucoup à dire sur
la savage de quoi vous dégoûter c'est
quand même l'ancien monde qui a décidé
de garder la main sur un certain nombre
de sujets financiers eric ce titre est
déjà questeur lui c'est quand même enfin
bon vous auriez souhaité du
renouvellement oui de la répartition
n'est pas très équilibré si vous voulez
on passe quand même en tout cas pour la
majorité macro nist on passe de florent
va se lier qui était arrivé en disant je
serai le chevalier blanc à eric woerth
qui a quand même comment dire un
itinéraire judiciaire assez complexe
dont ne pas dire assez riche donc
déploré que j'ai réuni que ces noms
c'est intéressant c'est à dire que c'est
vraiment vous savez le vieux monde se
meurt le nouveau monde peine à n'être
donc voilà donc quand on lance mais oui
pour répondre à votre question bien sûr
c'est très bien que yann brune qui vais
qui n'était pas élu il ya cinq ans qui
comme on dit viens de la société civile
qui a fait ses armes comme président de
la commission des lois moi je les
pratiques et comme présent la commission
des lois au début bon voilà elle était
peu habitué d'installer elle a fait
reconnaître son rôle bon avec par moment
enfin des petits sujets des sujets du
moment la création benalla pénale a
dépensé reste problématique
en même temps elle était présidente de
commission d'un maquereau nist d'un
gouvernement macro nist et comme on le
sait emmanuel macron été très très
impliqué de manière assez belle n'avait
pas forcément d un livre elle peut se
révéler aujourd'hui au perchoir en tout
cas et c'est très bien je sais c'est
assez au fond banal et le fait qu'on
s'en étonne montre quand même la cause
des femmes a encore beaucoup de progrès
à faire mais je lui souhaite bonne
chance est ce que vous êtes étonnée du
ton très modéré adopté pour l'instant
par les députés rassemblement national
est-ce qu'ils sont aussi en quête de
notabilité dans leur attitude
aujourd'hui évidemment c'est bien le
problème c'est qu'on tombe dans le
panneau c'est à dire que moi je vois et
le fait de politiques le plus marquant
de cette séquence sait bien que la
droite et la majorité macro nist et
décidé d'élire deux vice-présidents de
l'assemblée
le leur reprocher aujourd'hui absolument
pour russell so lu ment pas c'est qu'ils
ont permis cette élection mais suffit de
regarder les scores je dire que vous
suffit de regarder le nombre de voix et
on voit bien que voilà ils ont fait
beaucoup beaucoup plus de voix que les
voies du rassemblement national c est
donc oui je pense que c'est grave parce
que
marine le pen a réussi son opération de
banalisation eric zemmour lui a bien
rendu service également avec ses excès
ses caricatures sa violence qui a fait
apparaître marine le pen comme quelqu'un
de modérés qui aimait les chats et qui
était en coloc avec une copine et tout
ça a été formidable
du coup on voit et voilà c'est géré de
manière assez assez maligne mais les
idées d'extrême droite reste des idées
d'iphone droite le rassemblement
national c'est tout de même un groupe de
89 députés il fallait aussi normale
trois au vice président vous trouvez que
ça vaut pas ba2 non j'ai eu une vision
des médias les deux questions qui se
posent c'est à dire que premièrement
quelle est la ligne rouge qu'on
considère ne pas devoir franchir c'est à
dire que on a depuis que le front
national puis le rassemblement national
s'est installé sur la scène politique
française
certains ont considéré et il avait
raison qu' il ne faisait pas partie de
2,2 du champ républicain qu'on ne
pouvait pas les comparer avec les autres
formations petit mais ce que c'est
possible aujourd'hui quand ils ont 89
élus qu'ils ont on l ordination
d'ailleurs deux groupes le premier
opposition n'est dans une assemblée
politique donc tout a tout fait sens et
donc encore une fois
les installer à la présidence de
l'assemblée en vice président ce n'est
pas n'importe quoi
a fortiori de voter pour eux et de faire
qu'il y en ait deux et donc vous noterez
n'y a pas de vice président et l'air il
n'y a pas de visite à leurs dogmes
acronis mai et la présidence de la
commission des finances a elle aussi des
pouvoirs puissions eric coquerel à sa
tête il a été élu après plusieurs tours
de scrutin
ça ne vous pose pas trois mais certains
craignent qu'il impose les choses avec
un mois pour moi c'est cela aussi c'est
absolument normal à partir du moment où
on fait la révision
constitutionnelle c'est à l'épaule
nicolas sarkozy qui fait que c'est un
député de l'opposition donc ça veut dire
qu'il doit présider la commission des
finances c'est pareil au sénat
d'ailleurs donc nécessairement c'est
quelqu'un qui ait pas d'accord avec la
majorité bien ça aurait pu ados
rassemblement national qui convoitait se
porte très bien il ya beaucoup de gens
qui convoitent sauf que le premier
groupe lui non mais sauf que je ne sais
pas du tout ce que dit le règlement
règlement dit que ça doit être un député
de l'opposition après le seul truc c'est
que il faut que la majorité donc ne vote
pas vous avez remarqué qu apparemment il
ya eu des rumeurs disant qu'ils
pouvaient être finalement donc ils ne
votent pas et ensuite l'opposition donc
on est dans une situation qui est
inédite qui est un rassemblement de
gauche qui votent pour un député de
gauche ça me paraît assez logique donc
voilà donc je trouve ça après c'était
eric coquerel de deux d'occuper cette
fonction de manière la plus intéressante
possible mais franchement est alors
corps et on dit si si certains l air en
l'occurrence qui a quand même maintenu
son candidat pour fixer ses voix comme
on dit la magazine rassemblement
national on va enchaîner tout de suite
et bien sûr les premiers textes un conte
va examiner au mois de juillet le
parlement prévoit de travailler jusqu'à
début août
au programme le projet de loi un
sanitaire pour assurer une veille sur le
co vide le projet de loi sur le pouvoir
d'achat et le projet de loi de finances
rectificative on connaît bien les textes
qui vont être débattues mais reste une
inconnue le temps que ça va prendre à ce
sujet écouter le président du groupe
union centriste hervé marseille il ya un
certain nombre de groupes qu'on peut
qualifier peut-être de turbulents qui
peuvent allonger
les débats et les dénés donc en
particulier le texte sur le pouvoir
d'achat va être présentée tout dit-on
conseil des ministres le 6 juillet et
donc fera l'objet d'un débat avec plfr
dans la semaine du 20 à l'assemblée ce
qui veut dire que
ça ne sera pas chez nous avant une
dizaine de jours plus tard mais un petit
peu inquiet et préoccupé puisque
visiblement nous allons traîner jusque
début août ici au sénat et suivant les
travaux de l'assemblée dont on ne peut
pas mesurer
les dve et ça pourrait même constat mais
très largement le mois d'août on a aussi
appris à marie pierre de la gontrie que
le discours de politique générale
d'elisabeth borne aurait finalement lieu
mercredi prochain on pensait que ça
pouvait avoir lieu mardi et mercredi
prochains qu'est ce que ça vous donne
comme comme impression de l'impression
que ça prend quand même beaucoup de
temps à s'installer c'est vrai tout ça
est très étrange c'est à dire depuis la
présidentielle on a l'impression d'un
d'un pouvoir qui est totalement
à l'arrêt évanescent qui n'annonce rien
on voit que des ministres qui étaient
censés démissionner sont toujours là
puisque nouvelle nouveau gouvernement
n'est pas constitué donc histoire de la
santé par exemple il fait beaucoup
d'annoncés
à côté du lait
je prétends pas que les annonces c'est
l'alpha et l'oméga de la vie politique
mais quand même c'est à dire que du coup
on voit une espèce de flottement qui à
mon avis est très préoccupant et quand
on parle du texte sur pouvoir d'achat
moi je ne sais pas ce que tu dors c'est
à dire qu'on nous parle d'un texte qui
doit être adopté il n'y a pas eu de
conseil des ministres avait deux
semaines de suri a pas de pensée des
ministres donc soit on espère que ça ne
sert à rien les conseils des ministres
mais si ça sert à quelque chose c'est
quand même pas les étranges donc c'est
assez inquiétant il ya déclaration de
politique générale qui est prévu
elisabeth board sera devant le parlement
mercredi on connaît enfin la date
toutefois on ne sait toujours pas si
elle se soumettra ou non à un vote de
confiance
vous pensez qu'elle doit se soumettre un
vote de confiance je comprends que la
question soit complexe moi je d'abord ce
n'est je ne serai pas inédit qu'il n'y
en ait pas
mais cette fois c'est peut-être
différent hollande demandé tout est
toujours différent des élections oui
mais justement je ne suis pas sûr d'y
être favorable moi je suis pour que on
est un parlement qui fonctionne le mieux
possible on a une chance inouïe comme
parlementaire c'est la fameuse re
parlementarisation de la vie politique
française ne peut pas se plaindre à foix
des institutions qui font que finalement
tout est descendant depuis l'elysée que
nous quand on était sénateur renvoyé que
toute façon l'assemblée nationale décidé
tout bref ça va changer normalement
voilà avec le vote de confiance
nécessairement dans le vote de confiance
a confiance je ne sais pas comment ils
pourraient obtenir la confiance puisque
l'assemblée est composé de telle manière
que vous dites c'est pas de toute façon
moi je moi je souhaite plutôt qu'on
travaille sur des textes et donc elle ne
présenterait pas de l se soumettrait pas
au vote de confiance ça ne me choquerait
pas plus que ça
voilà donc nous verrons bien puisque
effectivement c'était prévu mardi c'est
repoussé à mercredi c'est assez étrange
là aussi on temporise beaucoup on n'a
toujours pas de nouveau gouvernement
qu'il arrive avance avant cette
déclaration de politique générale on
imagine que ça fait partie effectivement
de l'enjeu vous parlez de textes
effectivement le projet de loi pouvoir
d'achat c'est l'un des textes très
attendu au mois de juillet on connaît
quand même certaines mesures un
prolongement du bouclier tarifaire prime
transport remise carburant
revalorisation du point d'indicé
est-ce que sur l'esprit vous pouvez
voter contre ces mesures qui sont très
attendus des frasques est assez curieux
au passage c'est que tous ces textes ne
nécessite pas nécessairement une loi
toutes ces dispositifs à peu passer par
voie réglementaire chalumeau ne sais pas
encore non mais c'est intéressant parce
que pendant la campagne une des rares
choses qui a dit emmanuel macron ou ses
soutiens c'est qu'il y aura un texte par
résultat des courses et il faut qu'il ya
un texte alors que à mon avis il s'en
passeraient volontiers étant donné la
composition de l'assemblée on verra
l'ensemble du texte nous vous savez on
se bat beaucoup sur le smic
l'augmentation du smic on voit les
revalorisations de toute une série de
prestations mais qui sont en dessous du
niveau de l'inflation donc à ce stade
enfin nous socialistes on ne trouve pas
notre compte encore une fois de ce qu'on
entend c'est à dire une bribe
d'information et caetera et je pense
qu'on ne sera fixé étant donné le
flottement qui est au gouvernement on ne
sera fixé que le 6 juillet donc c'est au
sénat a enfin vous le savez aussi bien
que moi mais je comprends que vous posez
la question aux socialistes en général
on va voir l'ensemble bon mais j'ai de
ce que j'entends et a voulu me voir ce
qu'on va voir est ce que vous pensez
qu'il peut y avoir un socle commun entre
toutes ces oppositions différentes sur
des mesures phare ça dépend ce que vous
appelez des oppositions différentes
idées que moi je n'imagine aucun socle
commun avec le rassemblement national
voilà c'est simple je pense que c'est
très important de mettre une ligne rouge
et je n'ai pas compris que les
républicains puisque vous parlez d
opposition soit sur la même ligne que la
gauche sur toute une série de sujets sur
le pouvoir d'achat donc y aura peut-être
de ci de là des mesures qui conviendront
sur la globalité de ce que j'entends
encore une fois parce qu'on a on est
réduit mais vous aussi vous informations
qu'on peut glaner à droite à gauche je
suis peu convaincu mais il faudra bien
attendre
et à des débats interminables oui mais
surtout
c'est pas forcément inintéressant c'est
à dire que encore une fois on ne peut
pas se plaindre du fait qu'il n'ait pas
eu de débat suffisant les français de
manière générale kid c'est très
paradoxal ils votent peu et il adore la
politique c'est un débat très politique
donc avoir des débats sur tous ces
sujets confronter nos idées c'est très
intéressant et s'il faut cg le mois
d'août on sait que le mois d'août vous
dire que c'est notre boulot il n'y a pas
de sujet elle est fort probable on va
conclure marie pierre de la gontrie sur
l'embouteillage en vue autour des
propositions de loi pour inscrire le
droit à l'ivg et j'ai dans la
constitution alors qu'à l'assemblée
aurore bergé a annoncé porter un texte
en ce sens elle est devancée par deux
groupes politiques du sénat défendre le
droit à l'avortement fait consensus mais
l'avenir de ces textes restent
incertains on va voir ça avec à jérôme
rabier
les sénateurs communistes ont dégainé
les premiers il faut dire que leur texte
était déjà prêt déposées depuis 2010 est
leur proposition n'a jamais été inscrite
à l'ordre du jour est donc débattu ils
l'ont redéposer qu'on place l ivg aux
côtés d'autres droits fondamentaux qu'on
le met au même titre que les droits sur
la nationalité les droits sur la
préservation la préservation de
l'environnement donc des droits qui sont
fondamentaux et il nous semble important
de le faire entrer justement dans cet
article 34 de la constitution ça le rend
plus solide une inscription dans
l'article 34 qui ne satisfait pas tout
le monde le groupe socialiste donc
rédigé sa propre proposition qui vise à
inscrire le droit à lille et j'ai et à
la contraception au plus haut dans le
texte fondateur de la vème république
nous préférons monte d'un cran et passé
par le biais de du préambule de la
constitution mais globalement la
philosophie des interventions tant à
l'assemblée qu'au sénat rejoint en fait
l'objectif est l'objectif c'est il faut
préserver absolument le droit à
l'avortement et à la contraception
nous avons aussi rajouté dans le texte
fondamental de notre pays un objectif
commun mais des textes différents de
quoi brouiller le message et la
discussion parlementaire
d'autant que la droite n'est pas
forcément convaincu de l'intérêt de se
précipiter sur le sujet ils défendront
ivg s'il était menacé ça n'a jamais été
le cas dans notre pays je pense qu'en
quarante quelques années de vie
parlementaire personne n'a jamais ouvert
ce débat donc effectivement le leu leu
je pense que tout ce buzz est totalement
inutile et ne répondent pas à l'urgence
des français pour faire inscrire ce
droit dans la constitution deux moyens
sont possibles soumettre aux français ce
changement par référendum si le sénat et
l'assemblée vote exactement le même
texte ou alors réunir les deux chambres
du parlement congrès il faut alors une
majorité des trois cinquièmes pour que
cette modification de la constitution
soit adopté
marie pierre de la gontrie on entend les
arguments de la droite gérard larcher
qui dit qu'il faut se méfier des lois de
pulsions olivier marach ce qui dit eh
bien il faut pas importer ce débat qui
est vient des états unis est ce qu'il ya
vraiment urgence pour vous inscrire
divergé dans la constitution d une
impérieuse nécessité
d'abord ça fait des années qu'on se bat
à gauche pour ça donc on en parle peu
mais les socialistes via le député du
carvounas qui avait rassemblé autour de
lui d'ailleurs c'était les prémices de
la nu ps avait déposé il ya trois ans
une proposition de loi nous on a une
vision assez simple dans le groupe du
sénat et puisqu'on a déposé ce texte
avec mon amie laurence rossignol c'est
voilà il ya plusieurs rédactions proposé
géant veut dire peu importe prenons la
meilleure mais moi j'ai entendu le
premier ministre dire qu'elle était très
favorable il l'a redit très bien qu'elle
fasse un projet de loi et après le
changement de pied du coup on voit par
rapport à exercer ce mandat parce que on
l'a proposé à la précédente mandature
s'était refusée on a des interventions
de la garde des sceaux de l'époque de la
nouvelle présidente de l'assemblée
nationale qui était président de la
commission des lois donc faisons un
projet de loi il faut qu'ils abattent
bornes présente un projet de loi
pourquoi parce que du coup projet de loi
puis congrès ça peut être votée dans les
mois qui viennent et vous vous seriez
prête puisque vous devez déposer cette
proposition doit vous seriez prête à
voter un texte qui vient de la majorité
mais nous on est prêts à voter avec une
discussion vous savez enfin bon on voit
bien comment les choses se passent
personne n'a la majorité donc mettons
nous autour d'une table mettons nous
d'accord sur le texte le plus efficace
on a plusieurs versions non mais dans le
préambule du 46e peu importe en revanche
pour répondre à votre question
impérieuse nécessité oui vous savez que
il ya eu des offensives donc
olivier marc l'ex ce qu'il dit n'est pas
exact il des offensives via le
déremboursement c'est à dire que j'ai
déjà eu des amendements pour supprimer
le remboursement de lives et j'ai donc
fait menacer ce droit mais bien sûr j'ai
toujours rappelez vous il ya quelques
temps en espagne ils ont eu des
velléités pour le supprimer donc croire
que parce que ça a été voté par la
gauche rappelez-vous à l'époque sans la
gauche c'est la loi veil n'était pas
voté eh bien il n'y aurait pas de texte
sur les vg et donc ce qui se passe aux
etats-unis et la composition de
l'assemblée française avec cette
émergence bien sûr avec cette émergence
du rassemblement national le danger il
est là donc nous on continue notre
combat mais puisque le gouvernement a
changé de pied comme vous le dites que
la première ministre est désormais au
pied du mur présente un texte justement
si on arrive imaginons un référendum sur
le sujet est ce que vous ne craignez pas
une campagne très violente avec une
tribune talent médiatique ouverte aux
partisans du non au pro-vie ça pourrait
devoir d'exemple alors il ya un moyen de
l'éviter c'est pour ça que je dis que la
première ministre présente un projet de
loi et nous allons au congrès et c'est
voter en quelques mois donc
à la première minute aussi pour bien sûr
bien sûr s'être apaisées là où une
volonté il ya un chemin ce sera le mot
de la centrale mot de la fin merci
beaucoup henri pierre de la gontrie
merci katia c'est la fin de parlement et
dont on se retrouve la semaine prochaine
pour un nouveau numéro
[Musique]